how do you find your passion for what
businesses start i got a great question
from a youtube viewer love you guys uh
blah blah seven four five five
wrote in long message we're basically
saying i love what you're doing with the
videos
i don't know yet what my passion in life
is if you have any suggestions for my
business and how i could find what i
really like in life feel free to answer
me thank you in advance
so blah blah great question
this is the most important thing you
need to figure out with your company
before you get started so congrats on
spending the time to think about it and
and be willing to write in and ask for
help most entrepreneurs don't do that
and if you start a business just trying
to make money you're not going to
the most important thing to figure out
when you're starting a business is is
what is your passion
so there's a couple ways to do it okay
the first off think about things that
you love to do don't tie the business
yet just think about things that you
love to do things that you can get lost
in things that
you start at nine in the morning and you
look up and it's 33 in the afternoon
what do you love doing in life
okay then think about things that you
want to do things you haven't tried yet
but you have a deep desire to learn
about or experience
and number three think about
frustrations that you solve for yourself
things that you had a huge problem with
and you got so frustrated that you
couldn't find an answer anywhere so you
solved it yourself you made something
to solve that problem okay those three
things
make a huge list of all the ideas that
just come to your mind as you start
writing those things down okay so what
do you love doing you can get lost in to
what you wish you could do would spend
time on and three what frustrations have
you solved for yourself make a huge list
of those things
then you want to think about
where does it actually add value to
people's lives
okay the more value you can add to
somebody's life the more you're helping
them out the more money you're gonna
make the more of an impact you're gonna
have the more people are gonna pay you
to solve this problem for them so you
may like sitting down and playing video
games all day but if that's not adding
value to somebody's life then you're not
gonna be able to turn into a business
so if all the ideas that you wrote down
try to score them try to think about
which one has the most value
and the most successful business idea
that will come from that is the one that
matches up with something that you love
doing
and has a lot of value you can combine
those two things that is your powerful
winning business idea
i went through the same thing with my
business so when i sold my software
company i didn't know what i wanted to
do i didn't have to go work but i wanted
to work i i like work
and i was trying to figure out what kind
of business do i want to start and i
realized that i really loved helping
entrepreneurs
i could start talking entrepreneurs and
lose complete track of time if i feel
like i'm helping them with their
business or they're giving me ideas i
just love entrepreneurs
maybe i'm the crazy one i don't know i
love it i love hanging out entrepreneurs
i love talking to you guys
i lose track of time it makes my day
every day
i didn't know how to turn into a
business yet but i knew it had to be
something around helping entrepreneurs
and i played with my business model and
i found different ways to make it work i
started a website so now we have over 20
million people visited the website
i've done some coaching and consulting
work i've done some paid blog posts i've
sold advertising i've
tested out products for different
companies that still relate to
entrepreneurship so i've created this
little empire around helping
entrepreneurs because it's something i
believe in and i love doing
so
it's something i can get lost in so it
meets the first criteria and it adds a
lot of value to other people's lives
other entrepreneurs right why are you
watching this video why do i make these
videos because i love entrepreneurs i
love helping you guys out i love hearing
your questions i want to see you be
successful i want to see you build a
huge company
follow your dreams make some magic
happen change the world i love that
stuff
and so i surround that with me every day
i surround myself with that and so you
want to do the same thing with with
whatever business you start so finding
your passion you should get excited like
i just got excited right you heard the
passion come out in my voice you should
get excited for whatever it is that
you're gonna start to do
so go through that process
go through those steps that i mentioned
come down to the one idea that you love
and
adds a lot of value to people's lives
and you're on track to build a
successful company
i know it's hard i know it's challenging
i know
i know you want to start a business
right we want to want to get started we
want to wait don't want to go you know
spend all this time coming up with an
idea you want to get started now you
want to live the entrepreneurial
lifestyle i get it
you want to make sure you do it right
most businesses fail right eighty
percent of businesses fail in five years
eighty percent it's crazy
and a lot of them don't take enough time
on this first step
finding their passion figuring out what
they're excited about and building a
business around it
so congrats on taking the time to figure
that out
good luck
and believe
thank you everyone for watching if you
liked the video please give it that
thumbs up below makes me want to do more
for you and i want to hear what you have
to think please leave a comment under
this video or if you have a question for
your own company leave a comment below
and i will make a video response for you
thank you and i'll see you soon